hey guys I hate it when things sound
better than they actually are the idea
of you singing sounded great but the
actual no but seriously I'm talking
about romantic ideas those notions that
we get in our head that sound amazing
but when you put them into reality they
just suck take for example this common
and seemingly romantic scenario drawing
a bubble bath sipping on a glass of wine
poring over the words of a good book
sounds amazing right I feel like I'm
constantly being tricked by my
imagination it tells me to try all these
new things and in my head it plays out
perfectly but in reality maybe I should
ask him out that sounds amazing
you said he doesn't date children maybe
I should make a YouTube channel amazing
I should try building a stop-motion set
that sounds amazing Wow
actually this came out a lot better than
I thought it would I know yeah after
those last two cutaways that could have
sworn there was a batter in there but
putting it out I mean where does it end
there are certain things in life that I
know are romanticized but I do them
anyway any minute now something's gonna
happen mitch is single like any minute
now crime will happen well the vision in
our heads always be greater than reality
[Music]
our expectations of something always let
down over and put it I have telepathy
and it is the most mundane power ever
you have no idea how fucking boring
everyone's thoughts are okay well maybe
I'm exaggerating I mean after all there
are some realities that are better than
I could have ever imagined
[Music]
[Applause]